when the executive produces the new
lifetime movie about her life and it is
a wild ride
we've got your first look listeners want
to know this type of stuff i mean they
have a right to know
she looks and acts so much like me like
she got it
let me hear you how you doing how you
doing
[Applause]
how you doing the oval star sierra
payton relied on watching wendy's talk
show on youtube to nail
everything from her accent thank you
i'm going to play a song for you tony to
this
so we were literally in the hair makeup
trailer just playing it like on luke
it was the thing it will floor you you
will laugh you will cry you'll be like
well damn wendy covering the ups and
downs in the talk show queen's
tumultuous life
had its challenges so whitney are you
still using drugs
it was challenging for me um because of
the love and
you know respect that i have for both of
the women what i love about
wendy williams is that she goes there
and she holds something back
is there drug use going on at this
present time who are you talking to
to you whitney depicting wendy's past
drug use was actually triggering for
sierra
who says her family was plagued by
substance abuse
you're narcissistic you got a coke habit
they were also
a way for me to just kind of you know
work on my own healing
wendy williams is not going anywhere i'm
gonna come in like a hurricane
there is a resemblance there but you had
to make a few
extra added changes to play wendy
i wonder what you're talking about for
the audition
i just put a lot of socks and like three
bras on
nothing real to it under theirs